i'm travis smacka
i'm a public information officer for the
nevada highway patrol southern command
travis sm aka i'm here to give you a
brief update on the event that occurred
earlier today
on i-15 and near sahara
as i'm sure you're well and where now we
had an event earlier today
where we had a state trooper who was
attempting to deploy stop sticks who was
struck
by a suspect vehicle the
trooper is currently at umc in critical
condition fighting for his life
and we appreciate everyone's thoughts
and prayers in this very difficult time
for us
following our trooper being struck
the suspect vehicle was stopped and a
officer invite involved shooting did
occur
the suspect was pronounced the cson
scene it is very early in the
investigation and at this time that's
really all the information i have
we will definitely be providing more
information especially following the
72-hour briefing you see all of these
troopers gathered outside i mean how is
you know the law enforcement community
holding up right now
yeah we're leaning on each other it's
it's always very very tough i mean we're
we're like a family
and when one of us is
hurt and while
out there trying trying to do their job
we all feel it when
we're we're just all gathering together
trying to give all our support to our
fellow trooper and his family right now
can you tell us how old the trooper is
um
i actually don't have his age i
apologize for that but again um we will
be
providing more information
um i don't have that information yet but
we will be putting that out
shortly
his family is here along with as you saw
a lot a lot of his
fellow co-workers and myself what
prompted uh
a suspect being pursued for a felony
crime
and the our trooper was trying to deploy
stop sticks in order to
bring it to a safe conclusion at the
time he was tragically struck
you said the suspects being pursued for
a felony warrant no no
a felony okay can you tell us what that
time was um
this time i'm being told that they were
a suspect in a car chat
car did the carjacking happen today
that i don't know